in deutschland verbrauchen wir ungefähr
so 120 millionen kubikmeter und davon
verbrennen wir allein 60 millionen
tendenz stark steigend so aktuell
sondern zum beispiel kohlekraftwerk auf
holz umgestellt werden wobei die
wissenschaft sagt holz ist schmutziger
als kohle in der verbrennung aber egal
warum wenn man trotzdem machen weil die
weil die vossloh wie es geschafft hat
uns einzutrichtern holz ist co2 neutral
dabei ist es in der verbrennung
teilweise schlimmer als kohle und nur
auf co2 bezogen als wenn ich den baum ab
hacke und verbrenne leben wird das co2
frei ist völlig klar und ich brauche
dann teilweise jahrhunderte bis das
wieder gebunden wird wenn überhaupt wir
wissen ja gar nicht ob der wald hinzu
kommt dass überhaupt nur aufnehmen kann
weil wir immer weiter eine klima
schraube drehen aber wir feiern jetzt
erstmal so ungefähr und dann ist alles
gut natürlich quatsch und solche wälder
wenn sie intakt sind nochmal kühlen die
landschaft extrem runter und wenn ich
die attacke hat sich die landschaft auf
und was ist denn unser problem im
klimawandel die anderthalb grad die wir
anvisieren oder die
tageshöchsttemperaturen ein kleiner
unterschied wir liegen die auf demselben
breitengrad wie das kanadische städtchen
litten und die hatten jetzt knapp 50
grad bevor das daraufhin abgebrannt ist
das droht uns in zukunft und das bier
mögen das auch nicht und weil sie nicht
weglaufen können ändern die einfach das
lokale klima und wir müssen die einfach
nur machen lassen und denen ich ständig
und beiden mit der motorsäge stellen sie
schildern die situation so dringlich
dass man ja tatsächlich sagen müsste wir
brauchen von einem tag auf den anderen
so wie damals der kernenergie 1 1 ein
exit plan einen ausstieg wir dürfen
überhaupt nicht mehr so weitermachen wie
bisher nicht nur weil die plantagen auf
kosten der biodiversität gehen sondern
weil wir den wald aus klima gründen so
wahnsinnig dringend brauchen dass wir
uns diese holzwirtschaft um unser
überleben will wenn wir nicht wollen
dass bei uns die eifel dorf abbrennen
und so weiter einfach nicht mehr leisten
können warum dringen sie damit nicht so
durch das jetzt erwarten könnten jetzt
kommt die große wende na ja also es ist
halt so dass momentan die forst lobby
recht stark ist und noch mal dadurch
dass der staat so stark involviert es in
den holzverkauf
kann politik nicht unterscheiden ist das
jetzt pr oder sind das amtliche
mitteilungen und natürlich kommt das
immer als amtliche mitteilungen zum
beispiel der chef influenza der
bundesregierung der professor bruce das
offen forstwissenschaftler der sagt die
natur also übertragen die natur hat es
nicht mehr drauf als er sagt die
selbstheilungskräfte der natur sind ein
evidenz freies narrativ also die natur
kann es nicht mehr wir müssen bald
managen sprich abholzen wieder
aufforsten an der baumarten haider so
manipulieren manipulieren manipulieren
und dann sagt die bundesregierung okay
dann machen wir das und dann verbrennen
wir mehr holz dann versuchen wir mehr
mit holz zu bauen also die spirale die
dreht sich immer höher irgendwann wird
die abbrechen und wir sind kurz davor
wenn das zu dramatisch ist wie sieht das
grade schildern und stelle ich mir jetzt
einfach mal den situationen vor wir
haben ja gegenwärtig
koalitionsverhandlungen und man käme auf
die idee sie zum landwirtschafts und
minister der auch verfassten zuständig
ist zu machen wie sehr ihre agenda ganz
konkret aus also abgesehen davon dass
ich kein politiker wäre weil ich viel zu
wenig kompromissbereit wer also jetzt in
den koalitionsverhandlungen wir statt
ich sagen da stellen wir uns vor sie
sind jetzt der chef influenza der
nächsten bundesliga dann würde ich sagen
macht das belohnt waldbesitzerin und
waldbesitzer einfach ein system das war
ihre ausgangsfrage auch ja können die
mit sowas geld verdient und das können
die und zwar ist das fertig entwickelt
das system das man per satellit die
temperaturen von ökosystemen misst und
je kühler die sind desto intakter sind
die kann man wirklich 1 1 zu schneiden
und dann kann man die welt besitzenden
übertemperatur belohnt was sagen wir mal
das waldgebiet fühlt sich im schnitt
über die jahre um 8 grad ab im sommer
dann okay du kriegst förderung und die
nachbarin der im waldgebiet heizt sich
auf weil sie kahl geschlagen hat viel
holz genutzt hat ihr bekommt eben keine
fördergelder mehr das kann man voll
automatisiert abbrechen da bräuchte eine
ganz kleine behörde dies organisiert und
dann kann man diese gelder entsprechend
verteilt und wo kommen die gelder her
die man verteilt aus einer co2 abgabe
auf holz weil holz wenn holz so zum
treibhauseffekt beiträgt dann muss es
auch entsprechend besteuert werden mit
wie vielen spitzenpolitikern haben sie
über diese idee schon geredet na ja also
es sind weniger es sind schon ein paar
ich habe übrigens auch ein junger
blogger schon geredet so ist es nicht es
war bei dem früher seit mittlerweile max
ist mehr mit mir sprechen aber natürlich
sind es überwiegend grüne wie
erstaunlich gut informiert sind und
deswegen hab ich auch hoffnung dass da
was vernünftiges dabei rauskommt wenn
die ministerien hoffentlich entsprechend
besetzt werden
gibt es vielleicht auch grenzen in der
bisherigen rechtslage also die spannende
frage wäre ja zu sehen was darf ein
waldbesitzer mit seinem weiten machen
und was darf er nicht machen ich habe
keine kinder nicht wirklich im bilde er
muss zum beispiel sein wald öffentlich
zugänglich machen glauben also man kann
nicht eine große wälder vor der
öffentlichkeit versperren ja und auf der
anderen seite wird aber eine ganze reihe
auch noch von anderen auflagen haben was
er von forst wirtschaftlicher seite darf
oder was er nicht davor das sind aber
nicht allzu viel und so muss man sagen
da hat ja schon ziemlich großen spiegel
reicher ja also gut man kann jetzt nicht
könnt ihr leid abholzen wie er will also
ab einem bestimmten alter bis zu einer
bestimmten größe also die kahlschläge
ist die je nach bundesland in einem fall
ist es ein halber hektar in bayern das
glaub ich noch nicht mal ganz genau
definiert also das variiert von
bundesland zu bundesland wo man kann
schon relativ viel machen auch mit dem
maschinen da rein fahren und man kann
auch die baumarten im prinzip wählen wie
man möchte also da gibt es einen relativ
breiten spielraum klar es gibt das
betretungsrecht das freie das video
super das ist in deutschland nicht all
versuchen nicht besiedeltes land das
sonst jeder tages und nachtzeit durch
den wald strohmann daten erforderlich
auch jeden gern dazu auf das stellt die
tiere übrigens nicht die meisten geld
soll sowohl das volk teure das geht alle
gewalt und die armen tiere also einzige
was man machen sollte es nun soll laut
dabei seien sich gut unterhalten dann
müssen sich acht da kann man keine jäger
dafür haben wir angst und dann
entspannen die sich aber nochmal auf die
balten hier lauter man im weiler ist
umso mehr tiere sieht man was
ich nicht glaube ist ein satz den der
konkret und sagt du hast du bekloppt mal
vorbei gehen aber die entspannten sich
also schöne untersuchung dazu an mit
telemetriedaten tieren dass die sich
entspannen wenn die wissen da kommt kein
jäger das ist eigentlich das problem die
haben eigentlich nur angst projekt das
ist ja auch glaube ich der unterschied
zwischen waldgebieten je nicht bejagt
werden wo das wild sehr sehr nah an den
menschen ankommt gegenüber den besagten
und das hält sich glaube ich über
mehrere generationen ja also also dass
bei die angst
erst in der dritten oder vierten
generation aus dem tier wieder raus zum
beispiel in berlin in berlin haben die
wildschweine kaum noch angst vor dem
menschen warum weil in berlin halt keine
schicksten
erwarten sind wenn wir google möchte die
stadt fliegen würden deswegen sind
wildschweine zahlen ich habe vom
brandenburger thomas fuchs museen
currywurst gefressen hat ganz
entspannten gesagt öffentlich zugänglich
machen ist das was ich darf und dass es
insgesamt relativ wenig
reglementierungen gibt genommen aber ich
kann nicht hingehen und kann einen einen
alten wald nach gutdünken ab holz sind
also das ist geben sie unter grenzen
gesetzt oder prinzipiell nicht also der
stark macht es ja vor das ist in jedem
grenzen gesetzt seien da müsste man
quasi den wald ins recht setzen es gibt
ja die interessante diskussion dass man
über sich überlegt muss das rechtssystem
so geändert werden dass es rechte der
natur gibt also eine spannende
diskussion hier hat man den 70er jahren
in amerika angefangen ja also die bi die
so weit geht dass die frage ist darf ich
einen gequälten laboraffen
stellvertretend ja vor gericht im namen
des affen quasi klagen und bei uns wäre
das ja mit verbandsklage im prinzip
möglich dass ich sage im interesse des
waldes oder im namen des waldes klage
ich dagegen dass der abgeholzt werden
darf halten sie das für einen richtigen
weg oder setzen sie auf die
einsichtsfähigkeit der waldbesitzer ich
halte das erstere für den richtigen weg
also man muss klagen das ist genau der
grund für mich und meine frau ggmbh
gegründet habe eine gemeinnützige gmbh
die das genau zum ziel hat illegale
holzeinschläge in deutschland zu
verfolgen so zum einen haben wir
bestimmte schutzgebiete die einen status
haben zum teil nach eu-recht der mit
füßen getreten wird dort könnte man so
sehen sie jetzt vom nationalpark
nationalpark vor allem aber das sind
natura 2000 gebiete so ist es offiziell
also vogelschutzgebiete flora fauna
habitat es sind also sperrige begriffe
schutzgebiete diesen nach eu recht
geschützt da könnte man heute schon den
hebel ansetzen genau das werden wir auch
tun aber in vielen anderen fällen kann
man das nicht
ordnungsgemäße vor wirtschaft gilt immer
als naturschutz konform was haben ein
einfaches beispiel wenn sie zu hause im
sommer die hecke schneiden dann haben
sie das ordnungsamt vor der tür und
zahlen ordentlich strafe in hamburg
glaube ich bis zu 50.000 euro weil er
kenne ja für gedrückt worden ist ja auch
okay wenn sie das zugleich zeit im wald
machen sie hatten der bäume ab bis zum
gehtnichtmehr machender kahlschläge das
ist okay das ist ordnungsgemäßen
forstwirtschaft die ist doch immer
naturschutz konform so und jetzt kommt
die große preisfrage was ist
ordnungsgemäßen forstwirtschaft müssen
dass
ich auch nicht das ist es nämlich ließ
nicht definiert das ist doch cool also
ich kann immer sagen egal was ich mache
das ordnungsgemäße wenn der vaart ja was
ist das eigentlich na ja und das ist das
was ich mache wir haben ja gesagt einer
der gründe warum das möglicherweise so
ist hängt damit zusammen dass
der wald eine einzige männer kumpanei
ist also das ist so ein bisschen so im
bereich sv wo altes brauchtum und
traditionen so ausgeprägt sind dass das
recht da nie so tief eingedrungen ist
also dass das ist der punkt also das ist
eine tradition gesellschaft innerhalb
der gesellschaft also da kommen jetzt
auch zunehmend frauen dazu aber
eigentlich erst seit anfang der 80er
jahre eigentlich ist eine traditionelle
männergesellschaft durchschnittsalter
ist auch sehr hoch gerade die älteren
ränge das sind fast durchgehend männer
und man hat ein revier man ist unter
sich man geht auf die jagd man kann den
tag frei einteilen oder im deutschen
wald kann ja man noch man sein richtig
das ist das outdoor abenteuer und das
ganze als beamter bezahlt dass ich auch
cool sei in ordnung karriere machen nur
das system ist natürlich dann dadurch
auch nicht besonders reformfähig weil
alles was jetzt von außen kommen wenn
wir als gesellschaft sagen hey wir
möchten zumindest im öffentlichen wald
ein bisschen mitreden das empfindet man
als bedrohung jetzt ist ja ihr stärkstes
argument in der öffentlichkeit dass wir
mehr urwälder wieder brauchen weniger
plantagen weniger holz geschlagen wird
ganz stark die klimadiskussion ja also
wenn es nach dem klima geht kann man ja
gar nicht genug bäume haben und da
müssen wir vor allem die bäume haben die
besonders viel co2 speichern das sind
offensichtlich eher die großen und die
alten bäume und nicht so sehr die
plantagen und jetzt müsste man ja
deutschland ganz anders auffassen jetzt
müssen wir hingehen und müsste sagen wir
müssen das klima gesichtspunkten
auffassen und dann würden die bisherigen
waldflächen wahrscheinlich gar nicht
reichen sondern da wäre es ja sehr
interessant möglichst viele
landwirtschaftliche flächen entsprechend
wird mit bäumen zu besiedelt als co2
speicher
gibt es solche initiativen ist das ein
gangbarer weg kann man aus landwirten
fonds butter machen also ich würde
ungern aus landwirten volkswirte machen
weil irgendwann hat man ja dann wieder
die bäume ab und setzten das co2 wieder
frei sondern die wären dafür bezahlt
dass sie sich um die bäume kümmern und
dass er das für tatsächlich pflegen im
sinne von der creme und nicht pflegen im
sinne von hacke aber man kann natur
nicht fliegen es geht ja um natur es
geht ja gar nicht umfasst dabei kann es
schützen das andere zumindest keine
holzschuher und das kann man machen und
deswegen würde ich den begriff wechseln
also ich habe mich gerade einem
forstwirt sondern ich würde klima wird
innen und klima wird draus machen okay
also dass die an der landschafts kühlung
verdienen und dazu braucht man nichts
tun das ist das blöde da kann kein
grünes band beschneiden man kann nicht
so viel fördermilliarden verbuddeln der
wald kommt ja überall von selber zurück
setzt auf hausdächern oder
industrieruinen selbst in den
trockenjahren 18 bis 20 wachsender bäume
sagt wollny das wasser hier die haben es
noch richtig drauf man muss sie halt nur
lassen und ich ständig darum fummeln
also das ist das was uns so schwer fällt
aber kommen wir mal auf die fläche zu
sprechen ist nicht eigentlich
interessanter wir haben in deutschland
fast soviel tierfutter flächen die
waldfläche um die 100.000
quadratkilometer in deutschland ich
selber bin vegetarier aber wenn wir
jetzt mal sagt wenigstens ein bisschen
weniger fleisch könnten wir zehntausende
quadratkilometer wieder bewaldet und
dann sind aber den punkt die fläche
gehört ja jemand meist in privatbesitz
und das ist die fläche wo die
klimawirkungen klima wird richtig geld
verdienen könnten und wenn man das was
also wenn jetzt ein angebot macht dass
ihn die arbeiten können wenn man sagt
dass man auch sehen auch wenn du da
jetzt kein futter maisanbaus tja sondern
wenn du stattdessen das einfach
verwalten lässt dann verdienst du mehr
damit als wenn du da als tierfutter
produzent aktiv weiß dass man das so
gewann so müsste man es machen aber
immer muss dann gleichzeitig den
fleischkonsum drosseln weil sonst haben
wir ja greenwashing das heißt die tiere
futter flächen werden einfach nur quasi
ins ausland verlagert wir müssen mehr
soja importieren und so weiter und so
fort also wenn wir sagen wir legen hier
still und dessen weiter so viel fleisch
dann wird so anders gemacht aber die
drosselt man ja
das ist die frage das ist die frage ob
man das politisch steuert sprich über
steuern oder über teure und ist ein
schneller vorgaben es kann jetzt auch
mal sein dass man sagt
wir glauben keine gülle verklappung mehr
das ist ja mittlerweile eine
müllbeseitigung also wir importieren in
einem einst in einer einbahnstraße soja
und lasst uns durch die schweine melden
laufen und dann anschließend den boden
eigentlich müsste das tankschiff nach
brasilien zurückgefahren werden ihr
könnt natürlich hingehen können denen
den
fleischproduzenten in deutschland das
leben schwer machen das führt aber nicht
zu weniger fleischkonsum in einem
europäischen binnenmarkt sondern das
führt dazu dass hier noch mehr fleisch
aus dänemark holland oder polen
importieren ja das wäre die eigentliche
folge davon aber ich glaube wir brauchen
einfach erst mal eine andere erzählung
geborene erzählung was ist uns lieber
gehen wir auf den klassischen
sonntagsbraten zurück und haben
demnächst erträgliche sommer und nicht
mehr so lange dürreperioden oder wird es
immer schlimmer und wir essen einfach
noch fröhlich ein zwei jahrzehnte weiter
fleisch und dann kracht's aber durch die
auch mal günstige fleischpreise sind
seit jeher also seit der antike ja ein
sehr gutes mittel um die bevölkerung
ruhig zu halten ja also wenn der preis
des fleisches gemessen an seinen
umweltkosten verteuern würde dann gäbe
es ein ganz ganz erheblichem widerstand
den fürchtet jede regierung ja ich
glaube das ist ja nicht mein politik ist
kunst wie soll ich nicht dass die
politik aber natürlich machten zum glück
nur vorschläge aber ich glaube es wird
kein weg daran vorbei also wenn wir
klimaschutz nicht vor der haustür
praktizieren dann können wir global auch
irgendwann nicht mehr mitreden man ist
ja der klassiker das so gesagt na ja
also deutschland mit dem paar prozent
klimagase wir müssen auch china erwarten
auf indien warten auf russland warten
auf die usa warten nein wir können es
hier machen und das schöne ist es wird
hier schüler das den garten haben können
sie nachvollziehen oder in jeder straße
in der stadt provo bäume stehen ist es
kühler und zwar nicht wegen dem shoppen
möchte sich eine parallele unterm
sonnenschirm setzen unter bäumen ist es
immer kühler durch verdunstung und das
machen die in jedem kleinen hausgarten
das machen die in jeden straßenzug dass
man die im stadtwald ist noch nie ein
bundesland das kann man auf jeder ebene
machen jetzt frage ich mich noch ein
bisschen ich mein ich habe verstanden
was die vorzüge eines echten urwald sind
im gegensatz zu einer plantage
wenn es aber jetzt darum geht möglichst
schnell möglichst viel co2 zu finden
müsste ich ein interesse an wahnsinnig
schnell wachsenden wäldern oder
plantagen haben egal was es ist also ich
müsste halb deutschland mit pappeln zum
beispiel die im eiltempo wachsen ja und
relativ schnell in der lage sind co2 zu
binden selbst wenn die nicht soviel
binden wieder alte buche aber sehen sie
da nicht eigentlich die konkurrenz also
das sozusagen die neuen monokulturen
werden nicht mehr die fichten seien
sondern sind dann die klima pappe aus
zwei gründen zum einen sind solche
systeme instabile es gibt keinen
einzigen kunstwelt der so stabil ist wie
natur wald und wir wissen ja noch nicht
mal ob die naturwälder überleben im
rahmen des klimawandels und das genau
der punkt im moment hört man von allen
leuten wir müssen das kompensieren nein
wir müssen einsparen lassen ist ja
eigentlich kunst wir müssen endlich den
co2 ausstoß reduzieren und nicht
irgendwo irgendwie kompensieren im
übrigen selbst das ist ein starkes
argument für den erhalt des waldes das
ganze hat der derwald kompensiert bis zu
einem gewissen grade vielleicht nicht
ausreichend aber er konnte ja aber nie
aber nicht dass co2 sondern dass mein
stärkstes argument ist die kühlung und
die regenwolken bildung das macht wald
und natürlich und ist im sinne einer
moralischen bereich wer gibt uns
eigentlich das recht den größten teil
der landschaft in deutschland ist nicht
manipuliert nun 0,6 prozent der rest ist
komplett manipuliert mehr gibt uns
eigentlich das recht uns so breit zu
machen auf kosten all der anderen arten
also wir lassen den 0,6 prozent um sich
zu entfalten und auf den restlichen 99 4
prozent sagen dass also das machen wir
uns schon alles besser und das recht
leitet sich daher ab dass noch nie
jemand aufgestanden ist und den menschen
dieses recht erstritten hat ja und da
sie beide ihren vorschlag oder bei ihrer
frage müsste die natur nicht auch ins
recht gesetzt werden und da sage ich
ganz klar selbstverständlich
also das ist ja ein ziemlich gewaltige
revolution die wir machen weil wir den
anthropozän tourismus ja der sehr eng
mit unserer kapitalistischen wirtschaft
zusammenhängt auch wenn er vielleicht
ursprünglich von den antiken story kommt
aber da hat er sozusagen sein
wirtschaftliche umsetzung gefunden die
müssten wir sagen so geht das nicht
weiter
die wissen andere prioritäten setzen ja
die natur ist nicht nur kostenfaktor
oder eine ressource oder irgendwas
sondern hier hat ein eigenes rechner und
ein eigenes interesse und diese idee
würden sie auch stark machen und
verfolgen ja vor allem weil es auch
schöne ist ich glaube viele leute haben
deswegen ein problem damit weil sie
natur als etwas exklusives sehen also wo
wir nicht rein dürfen das schießt uns
aus und das ist ja gar nicht der fall es
schließt nur den manipulierenden
menschen aus alles andere quellen machen
wir können entspannen wir können freude
haben das ein emotionaler gewinnen und
zwar in doppelter hinsicht wenn wir
natur so betrachten hier natur da wir
dann sind wir ziemlich allein ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich würde gern
dazugehören also wenn wir uns als teil
einer großen gemeinschaft betrachten das
ist doch viel befreiende jaaa und
wahrscheinlich auch viel gesünder für
unsere zukunft ich glaube der ein oder
andere forstwirt der uns hierzu gehören
hat dann eine andere
forstwissenschaftler vielleicht auch
eine vorhin von ihnen genannte chefin
friends eine bundesregierung die würden
sagen das was der wohl leben da erzählt
das ist hoffnungslos romantisch
würden sie den begriff romantiker
abweisen oder wird und sich sagen ich
bin stolz darauf einer zu sein also
weder noch aber ich finde es mut also
glaube wir können gar nicht genug
romantik brauchen also man kann es auch
anders sagen uns fehlen die emotionen in
der diskussion und das emotionale also
es kommt mir viel zu kurz das ist doch
total wichtig was wollen wir denn im
leben haben wollen wir möglichst vier
rohstoffe arbeiten oder wollen wir was
ganz anderes nämlich ein glückliches
leben führen dass immer genau im bereich
liegt das problem wie einfach dahin dass
eine bestimmte art von vernunft also von
rationalität herr die instrumentelle
vernunft die ökonomische verwertung die
es absolut legitim in unserer
gesellschaft und wer daran zweifelt und
emotionen wie sie gerade ja da in die
waagschale wirft der gilt eben sehr
leicht als weltfremder spinner idealist
weltverbesserer oder irgendetwas anderes
jetzt denke ich ja immer es gibt ein
argument was sehr stark für die romantik
spricht für die romantische sichtung es
sehr sehr viele menschen haben diese
romantische sichtweise oder sie haben
sie zumindest in dem moment wo sie durch
den wald gehen deswegen ist er weiter
aus so mythisch aufgeladen und ich denke
wir immer der mensch ist ja ein tier das
instinkte verfügt und irgendwo etwas
instinktives führt dazu dass er uns vom
wald verzaubern lassen ja und es ist ja
auch interessant
aus irgendeinem grund muss das ja da
sein also ein romantisches verhältnis
zum wald kann es ja nur deswegen geben
weil menschen über die fähigkeit sich
vorm wald verzaubern zu lassen überhaupt
verfügen das kann man sogar
wissenschaftlich benennen
das sind sowie atmen baum kommunikation
ein diese führten ziel das kommt
übrigens auch riechen an heißen
sommertagen denn so nadelwälder anderes
riecht so wird sich hüten ziel der
pflanzenstoffe die ausgedünnte werden da
waren die sich gegenseitig von
borkenkäfern und irgendwie andere
geschichten warten dass ein unser
blutdruck sinkt messbar ich hab selber
schon mal ausprobiert und die
übersetzten das dann ins bewusstsein mit
auch hier ist was schön dann kommt das
romantische raus ist letztendlich
setzung einer körperlichen reaktion
pulsschlag verändert sich rückstaus geht
runter gehen schon unter druck das ganze
wirkt je nachdem wie lange draußen ist
sogar noch für tage nach so und das
macht auch sinn evolutionär weil
ökosysteme die im takt sind also wir
besser der wald in schuss also
ökologisch desto besser ist diese
wirkung und wir können dadurch intuitiv
beurteilen ist das ein gutes ökosystem
jetzt im sinne unserer vorfahren vor
10.000 jahren ist das ein stabiles
ökosystem mit einem stabilen bildbestand
bricht da nicht gleich alles zusammen
das können wir sofort beurteilen den wir
sagen auch hier so schön
das heißt also hinter dieser romantik ja
gibt es nicht nur einen natürlichen
instinkt des menschen zu wissen das ist
ein ort sondern es gibt eine sehr
evidenzbasierte biologische
wissenschaftliche grundlage dafür dass
diese romantik eine völlig berechtigte
sichtweise ist also ich meine zumindest
so berechtigt was die ludwig maximilians
universität in münchen eine zeit lang
sogar therapeuten in dem sinne
ausgebildet haben also dass da kommt man
immer mehr dahin letztendlich muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen man muss das auch
nicht bis zum letzten schlüsseln das
sind ja unsere letzten lebensräume wo
man mal in fußläufiger oder so mal pnv
entfernung was erleben kann und muss
nicht in ferne länder reisen sondern
kann sich mal wieder erden im wahrsten
sinne des wortes das hat doch auch ein
wert